hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes in which I recap the most
ravishing language and ideas from the
last week of Wired first step today
we're taking a dive gadget lab
catalogued the sad decline of the patent
drawing which was once a beautiful
illustration and has now become an
aesthetic catastrophe one of these
patent drawings was for a diving dress
and no this is not a fancy waterproof
gown it was the classic diving suit with
a metal helmet and hoses running to the
surface I suppose if you really wanted
to drape a gown over the top of it while
the diving dress has been around in
primitive forms for hundreds of years
its heyday was in the first half of the
20th century when is particularly
popular among navies it was eventually
replaced by scuba gear mostly because
while wearing the 200-pound diving dress
sailors could only manage the strength
to be the M in the rendition of the YMCA
dance and they were sick of it as the
diving dress era waned the undisputed
master of the medium emerged diver Dan
and his eponymous children's show he
walked along the seafloor talking to
fish causing a villainy were barren
barracuda and his sidekick trigger whose
eyes were half closed not because he
appears to be smoking reefer but because
he had bad allergies apparently all
these fish were messed up on allergy
medication because they took an
awkwardly long time to reply to each
other he had come huge after all
well see Goldie would have been that
poor well maybe they were just
distracted by the clearly visible
strings sprouting from their backs up
next a symbol so cute it makes the
exclamation and hash marks question
their own sexuality is too loopy the
fluffy the cozy at sign wired enterprise
profile a man by the name of Ray
Tomlinson was responsible for the @
symbol showing up in your email address
and he chose it because he said it was
the only preposition on the keyboard
which is probably true though could turn
out that the carrot is also a
preposition just as soon as somebody
figures out what the hell carrot is the
@ symbol first showed up way back in the
16th century an emergent used it as an
abbreviation for amphora which was a
measurement equal to about three gallons
by the time ray Tomlinson adopted it for
email and have long been used to mean at
a rate of or more simply at languages
that hadn't used the @ sign had to
scramble to name it once email exploded
and they got pretty creative with it in
Denmark where there are no elephants
it's called the elephant's trunk in
Germany where there are no monkeys
called the monkey's tail and in
Kazakhstan they call it the moon's ear
because well why not there's even a way
to express the symbol in Morse code
which is nice if you happen to be on a
sinking ship and want to send one last
email before joining diver Dan and is
slow to respond comrades
you